so we know that trevor lawrence is gonna
be number one at the jaguars unless
something happens that stuns a zack
wilson number two to the jets unless
something happens that stuns us we then
lock on to the 49ers at number three
many believe chris including you that
it's gonna be mac jones the alabama
quarterback interesting exchange
yesterday between alabama coach
nick saban and dan patrick on the level
of communication or not that he's had
with the 49ers about mac jones here's
the question from dan and saban's answer
what did you tell kyle shanahan about
mac jones
he didn't ask me a thing
didn't ask me a thing i said hi to him
john lynch too
they did not ask me a thing about them
they didn't ask me a thing wow maybe
they thought they weren't allowed to
because
you know out there on the pro day floor
which is where i saw them yeah you know
i i think that they they i don't know
all their rules but i think their
wizards are not really allowed to talk
to me
i've never heard that before we saw the
picture of urban meyer standing next to
dabo swinney at trevor lawrence's pro
day i i i don't i don't know
what what kind of i'm not going to be
the alabama coach game sabin's playing
there but i
i i
no i know i don't know i don't know
maybe he i don't get it
but i i've never heard of that either
i'm with you i talked to him yeah he
talked to him there you talked to him
after and remember one of the things
sabin said in the past yeah these guys
don't talk to me belichick's the only
one who talks she'll be right right yeah
so presumably kyle uh and and i know
that for some of these guys it's like
going to see the wizard of oz
and you're the cowardly lion and you
really don't want to go approach
nick saban because of what he's
accomplished and because of his demeanor
and his personality but for something
like this you better you better check
that box especially when you have the
invitation the the statement that saban
made in the past his invitation to any
nfl coach to call him up and find out
about his players yeah no i i mean
agreed i don't think shanahan's like
intimidated that way i mean listen he
grew up with mike shanahan who's also a
legend so uh i don't think it's about
that i do think and we kind of heard
this
was this you know
last week i think early last week you
know
shanahan's private with this stuff you
know he he keeps it close to the vest
there's a reason you talked about like
yeah you want him in the car to when you
play poker you don't know his you know
his tells
he he's he's i think probably more than
anything just afraid to share thoughts
and things because he doesn't want to
give anybody a tell at this point of
where he's going and all of that but you
know i will say this
you know shanahan like a belichick
he doesn't think he's right about
everything he does not you know that one
of the reasons i think he's great
offensive play caller is because he's
always looking for more another idea who
can i steal from what can i do i don't
know everything teach me a new way to do
this what okay you know that's what the
great coaches do i think when it comes
time to where okay shanahan feels like
he's got all his ducks in a row he'll
call a nick saban if he's got his eye
really on mack jones and he wants to
make him the number three pick and he'll
pick his brains and do that uh i i but
we heard shanahan last week saying one
of the reasons he doesn't want to go to
those pro days really is because he
doesn't want people to know where he's
leaning you know as far as his picks and
the draft and everything like that so uh
i i think that conversation will happen
at some point
and at this point as shannon had
acknowledged last week it doesn't matter
they are where they are they're taking a
quarterback right and they're going to
get trevor lawrence zach wilson or
whoever the third guy is that made them
comfortable enough to go up that far
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports